[Music]
Mark's here okay
have you noticed marks when acting a bit
different ever since that has sexy mark
hashtag started trending what do you
mean
[Music]
see you seriously just didn't notice
that whole thing right there what he was
just getting into something a little
more comfortable but it's in the way he
did it in what way
[Music]
that that right there what the sexy
thing I don't I don't know what you're
saying
honestly just look
[Music]
the mark you spilled a little bit on the
ground over there I mean don't worry I
know he poured it onto himself sexually
you know what man that's how you see
he's doing it intentionally
[Music]
stop you know what Ryan you stop okay
well he's being nice and making us
breakfast you're turning this into some
perverted fantasy thing I don't know
well I see mark trying to make us eat
his pancakes sexually he can do whatever
he wants
okay now you get these little fantasies
the sexual perverted fantasies out of
your head because he's just acting like
a normal guy you're the pervert you're
sexualizing this this is an issue we
deal with in our country today overt
sexual ization now leave him alone and
leave me alone because my favorite show
is on right now let me watch it
[Music]